PENG YING: Hi, and welcome
to Google Developers Live.
My name is Peng Ying,
and with me today
is the newest member
of our team, Maru.
MARU AHUES: Hi.
Happy to be here.
PENG YING: So for this
Google Developers Live,
we'll be talking
about Wallet Objects.
And specifically, we'll be
talking about how to get you up
and started with our
Quick Start samples.
We have several
Quick Start samples,
and the one we're going to
be focusing on today is Java.
What the Quick
Start does is it's
designed to help you
hit the ground running
in your integration.
And it showcases several things.
One is authorizing
access, and two
is inserting a new
Wallet Objects class.
Three is using the
Save To Wallet API
to insert a Wallet
Object, and then lastly,
using the Web Services API
to enable instant sign-up
and linking from the
Google Wallet app.
You can find
detailed instructions
on setting this up in
our documentation, which
you'll see on the
screen right now.
And to walk you through these
instructions, here is Maru.
MARU AHUES: Thank you, Peng.
So as Peng mentioned, and you
can see on my screen right now,
we have the Java Quick
Start documentation.
And here, we have detailed steps
on how to get your credentials,
download the project,
configure it, and run it.
What we'll do today is go
through all of the steps
and show you a demo on the
phone on how this works.
So to start, the first
thing that we need to do
is get our credentials.
To do that, I recommend
that you watch a previously
recorded GDL.
It's called Wallet
Object API Account Setup,
and this will show you
how to create your account
and how to get your credentials.
And once you have that
set up, all you need to do
is just go into-- first let
me go here-- get your issuer
ID from your Merchant
Dashboard, and also make sure
that you have your service
account created on the Google
Cloud Console.
So go to the Google
Cloud Console,
click on Register Apps, then you
can click on Service Account.
And this is my Service
Account, test, and then
this is my email address.
So I'll need my email
address, my merchant
account ID, and
also the private key
that you downloaded when you
created your credentials.
So once you have
those three things,
we can go and download
the Quick Start.
To do that, the Quick
Start code is open source,
and you can find it on GitHub.
To do that, go to
github.com/googlewallet,
and you can find it on
googlewalletobjects-quickstart-java.
So once you're here,
you'll see that you
have the option, of course,
to either clone or download
the code.
We're going to clone it
locally here to show you.
So I'm going to
open my terminal,
and just going to do--
PENG YING: You also
didn't get installed,
but there's not a
tutorial for that.
MARU AHUES: Or you
can just download it,
and that would be
easier, probably.
Then just clone here.
And it's going to take a
couple of seconds, or more.
PENG YING: Oh, man.
The internet is a
little bit slow today.
MARU AHUES: So while we wait for
the clone, then the next step,
we need to make sure that
you have Eclipse installed.
So if you don't have
it, then pause this
and then go install
and then come back.
And once this is done--
OK, this is done now.
PENG YING: You also
need the Google Plugin.
MARU AHUES: Yes.
So let's go into
our Eclipse now.
So now that we
have it downloaded,
let's see where it is.
I'm just going to go
into my directory.
We have the code in here.
We're going to open Eclipse.
And I'm just going to create
a new workspace for today,
just to test, to make sure that
I don't have anything there.
PENG YING: Workspace four.
MARU AHUES: So now that we're
here, what we need to do
is first import the
Quick Start into Eclipse.
So as Peng mentioned,
we also need
to have the Google
Eclipse Plugin.
So let's do that first.
First check if you
already have it.
Maybe you have already used
it for another project.
Just go into Help,
Install New Software,
and then check here where it
says what's already installed.
And on my list, I have it--
Google Plugin for Eclipse.
But if you don't
have it, then all you
need to do is go into
our documentation,
and it has the link
for the site where
it needs to be downloaded from.
I already have it here.
So it's
dl.google.com/eclipse/plugin/4.3.
And this is, of course,
related to the Eclipse version
that I'm running.
So for a different
version, you will
need to use a different URL.
So once you click
this, just click Enter,
and this will load a list of
all of the plugins or tools
that we have available
on that site.
For this project, you only need
the Google Plugin for Eclipse,
right?
PENG YING: Yep.
MARU AHUES: So you just click
on that, and then click Next.
PENG YING: We've actually
included the App Engine
dependencies, or a specific
version of App Engine
within our GitHub project,
which is why you don't also
need to download a
version of App Engine
when you're installing
this plugin.
MARU AHUES: That's
great to know.
So the only thing we need to
worry about to make it easier
for you guys is just to
download this plugin.
So we'll do that.
In my case, because
I have it, it
says that I need to update it.
So I click Next, and
it will update it.
For you guys, it will
probably just say Finish,
and then you will install it.
I'm not going to update
it right now, to make sure
that we don't spend
too much time on that.
So we have that.
And now let's import the code.
To do that, all we do is
just click on File, Import.
And then from here, we're going
to select General, and then
Existing Projects
Into Workspace.
For our root
directory, we're going
to use the same directory where
we cloned our code from GitHub,
or where we downloaded it.
So in my case, I have that
under Development, quickstarts,
and then
walletobjects-quickstart-java.
So I'm just going
to click on Open.
And as you can see here,
it has the project,
and that's all what
I need to do here.
I don't need to
check anything else.
I just need to click on Finish.
So now this is going
to import the code.
And once it's done--
OK, so we're done here.
What do we need to do next?
So now, what we want
to do is configure
the project with
our credentials.
To do that, we have two steps.
The first step is to
copy our private key
into the war WEB-INF directory.
So let's do that here.
I'm into the directory here, and
I have my key on the directory
above, so wobs-privatekey,
and I'm going to copy it
into war/WEB-INF.
Once I have it there--
let me refresh here--
so my key's there.
So that's the first step.
And the second is we're
going to configure
our credentials in the web.xml.
So just double click the
WEB-INF web.xml file,
and click on Source
so we can edit it.
Let me close out Outline here.
And if you scroll
down, you'll see
that we have here
four configuration
parameters that
we need to change.
The first one is the
service account ID.
And this, as it says here is
your OAuth service account
email.
So let me go back to the
browser to copy that.
And this is my email, and I'm
just going to copy that here.
My private key, in this case, I
called my key wobs-privatekey.
PENG YING: Very descriptive.
MARU AHUES: I try
to be descriptive.
And then the issuer ID, I'm
going to also come and copy
paste that from the
Merchant Dashboard.
And I also need to enter
my application name.
So for the application
name, don't worry.
This doesn't need
to match anything
that you've already
created before.
This is used only
for OAuth purposes.
So when the user logs in,
it says on the pop-up,
you're logging in and
you're giving permission
to this application to
use your information.
So of course, this needs
to be application name,
but it doesn't match anything
that you've previously created.
So in here, I'm going
to put Maru's Test.
And so that's it, pretty much.
We're done.
PENG YING: Yeah.
Let's run it.
MARU AHUES: So
fairly easy, right?
So now, what do we want to do?
We want to run it.
The next thing we do is we're
going to click on the Run,
and then we're going to run
this as a web application using
our Google Eclipse Plugin.
Once we do that, let me
open this so you can see it.
PENG YING: That was quick.
MARU AHUES: It was fast.
And it's already running.
And now, you can
see it's running
on local host, port 8888.
That's not an easy one.
So what we're going to
do is open another window
and run this here.
So what you see now on my
screen is the Quick Start code
running.
And like Peng says,
we are showing you
three different functionalities
with the Quick Start.
The first one would
be to insert classes,
which is what you're going
to do with these two buttons.
The second one is to
insert the objects,
and we're going to do that using
the Save To Wallet buttons.
And then the third one is
the web service integration.
That's going to let
you test and work
with the Google
Wallet application.
We'll show you that
one afterwards,
after we're done with this.
PENG YING: Typically,
you wouldn't
want to have a button
to insert a class.
Typically you just do
it on your back end.
But because we're demonstrating
how to issue that request,
we have the button here to tell
our server to take that action.
MARU AHUES: And
that's good to know.
So these buttons, you won't
have those on your site.
But they're good for
testing and for debugging.
So we're going to click
Insert Loyalty Class.
And once we do that,
let's look here.
It's going to show me
that the class already
exists because we've already
inserted it testing the Quick
Start before.
So that's good.
If you keep clicking
on that, it will just
give you this error message,
which is not an error.
The class is unique, so we
can only insert it once.
And after that, once
we insert the class,
we can go ahead and use the
Save To Wallet button and insert
the object or associate
the card with my user.
If I mouse over
the button, you'll
see that I'm signed
in here as John Smith.
If I wasn't logged in, it
would tell me to log in,
I would click on it,
and it will allow
me to log in as a Google
user with a Google account.
So now I'm going to click
on Save Card To Google.
PENG YING: And if you
look at your Wallet App,
you can actually see the card
inserted into this Google
Wallet demo account.
And then we can actually take a
look at what the card contains.
So if we click into
Baconrista Rewards--
this is our demo merchant, of
course, a demo loyalty card.
You can see that we've
created a bar code, that we've
given this user points, that
we have a tier for the user,
and the additional information
about the user associated
with the account.
And if you want to
take a look at that,
you can check out the
Loyalty Vertical class,
which will show you how
we've defined all of that.
And I think Maru will
go through it as well.
MARU AHUES: And we can go
through it in detail now.
So now, we have the
class and the object.
And let's look at
some of the code then.
So we go back into Eclipse.
I'm going to stop it just
so we can look at the code.
So the first thing we should
look at is the index.html.
So when we load the
Quick Start, you'll
see this is our index page.
And what we have is, like we
said, the buttons to insert
the classes, and also a
Save To Wallet button.
So we're going to
see here in our code
that we have those
buttons here, and also we
have the step two buttons
for the Save To Wallet.
We're also including the
JavaScript here in this file.
Let me open it so
you can see it.
What it's doing is
that it's mapping.
So it's mapping.
The Save To Wallet
buttons are being mapped
to the JWT or the
"jot" handler, and what
this is going to
be doing is it's
going to be generated
in the code that's
going to render the button.
And we'll show you in
detail how this works.
Also, we have the code here for
the Insert Loyalty and Insert
Offer buttons.
And so they're also linked.
When you click on
them, they're going
to be calling the insert handler
here, or the insert servlet.
So now, let's see
what those are doing
if we go back into our web.xml.
Let's look for
Insert first in here.
We're mapping this
path to the WOB insert
servlet, which is here.
And we're mapping
the JWT or the "jot"
to WOB generate JWT servlet.
So if we go now
into the source, we
have a package for our servlets.
And then let's look
first at the insert.
So in here, what do we do?
When you click on the button,
the first thing that happens
is that we're going to create
an object with the credentials
that you defined
in your web.xml.
And then we're
going to check which
is the type which we're
sending in the URL
from when you click
on the button.
So in our case, we're
testing loyalty.
So type is loyalty.
So we check if the
type is loyalty,
we're generating
a loyalty class.
And once we do
that, we are calling
the API to insert
that loyalty class.
When we do this, first we
use our loyalty object here.
And let me look at it.
And this is what Peng
was referring to.
When you want to modify what
are we have in the Quick Start,
all of the fields and
parameters and the information
that we're displaying in our
loyalty class and object test,
you come into the
loyalty vertical.
And this can be found
under the verticals--
let me open it-- the
vertical package.
So let's look at
the loyalty class.
So in here, you can see
we're setting the header,
we're setting the body,
we're sitting an image
for "back-in-rista"?
PENG YING: Baconrista.
MARU AHUES: Baconrista.
We're putting some header
details and some messages,
so all of the information that
you can set on a loyalty class.
And you can find more details
about this in our documentation
if you go to the templates
or our loyalty tutorial
you're able to do through
our loyalty class.
If we go back here, when we're
calling client loyalty class
insert, we're calling
our client library
that is making the API call
to insert that loyalty class.
And the same happens
for our other verticals.
Once we do that, then
that servlet's inserted,
and then responds back to us.
Anything you want to add here?
PENG YING: No.
MARU AHUES: Great, so
then for the JWT servlet,
it's very similar.
We're also going to
create our credentials.
And then in here, we
have a list of origins.
And it's adding
your URL or the site
where you're running--
so you really don't
need to modify this-- and also
checks the type, which we're
also sending from
the JavaScript here.
If we see here, we
have the type loyalty.
And once we have the
type, we check the type.
And then in this case, instead
of generating a loyalty class,
we're now going to be
generating a loyalty object.
So the difference here is
that we are creating a JWT.
So we create a JWT, and we
add the object to the payload.
And once we do that,
here, we generate the JWT,
and we are signing it
and sending it back
to the page and the button.
PENG YING: A JWT is basically
base 64-encoded JSON
with a signature from some
sort of HMAC-SHA1 hash,
or whatever encryption
algorithm you want to use.
MARU AHUES: In these
JWTs, what's important
is that we are generating
them on the fly for testing.
But you can pre-generate
these and save it
on your button in
the HTML directly.
So that would save, of
course, the time of processing
when the page is loading.
But for this demo, we do
this so you can very easily
modify the servlet or
any of the information
that you have on the vertical,
on the loyalty object,
and then test it without
having to change your index
HTML every time.
Once we have that, what
else do we have in here?
We also have the web
service, but we're
going to talk about the
web service in detail
after we finish this
part of the demo.
Now that we've gone through the
process of inserting a class
and also generating the WT to
save the object to your Wallet
using the Save To
Wallet button, Peng
is going to show us how we
integrate your discoverable
with the Google Wallet app
using the Web Services API.
PENG YING: Yep.
So what the Web Service API does
is it enables instant sign-up
or linking from within
the Google Wallet app.
For example, I could
sign up for Walgreens,
or I could link my Belly
rewards with a simple click.
And right now, what I'm going
to show you is signing up
for Baconrista Rewards,
our demo rewards
merchant, or loyalty merchant.
So I have my programs here,
and to add a new program,
to sign up or link
from a new program,
I click the plus button.
And I scroll down to
my rewards program,
which is-- its easy, Baconista
Rewards that we've enabled.
I click into it, and I
have sign-up or linking.
And both of these are
powered by Web Service API.
So I can click Join Now.
And these fields that you
see on the screen right now
are actually defined
by the merchant
inside the discoverable.
So if you're a
merchant, and then
you don't require
all of these fields,
or you require a few
additional fields,
you can choose the specific
ones that you need.
For example, if I
need the phone number,
I would request the phone
number from the user as well.
And typically, all
of this data is
stored within the
user's account,
so they never have to
enter any information.
They can just scroll
down, accept the terms,
and click-- if I had less fatty
fingers, click Create Account.
And that's it.
I've signed up for the program.
I'm now a member.
I can go into my
objects and take a look
at my rewards details.
And to tell you
how it works, Maru
will show you the handlers
on the server side
and the configuration
of the discoverable.
MARU AHUES: So how this magic
works, it's some very simple.
The idea is that whenever
you click on the app
Google will load
the discoverable
that you have set in live mode.
And once that's loaded on
the phone and someone clicks
on either Join or
Link, I'm a member,
or join the program,
what's going to happen
is that Google will send you the
information, the JSON request,
to your Web Service API.
And how do we do that?
We can define what that
web service endpoint
is by going into the
Merchant Dashboard
and going to Merchant
Callback Configuration.
And here, you can
see we have the host,
we also have the port, and then
the path is the web service.
And this is what we have
defined on our Quick Start.
Of course, this could change
based on your implementation.
So for us, now we have our
Quick Start running on this App
Engine site, under
wobs-maru.appspot.com And when
Google sends the JSON request
to my web service endpoint,
we send back a payload that
includes the object information
that we want to save
on that for that user.
So based on either whether it's
a linking, when the user said
that they were
already a member, we
will receive the member ID
and the request from Google.
Or if it's a new
member, then you'll
get all the new
member information.
So then you can create a
new Google Wallet object.
PENG YING: And the
auth token here
is actually a token
to authenticate
that this is coming from
Google, that the messages sent
to your server are
being sent from Google.
And it'll actually
be a header element
within the HTTP request.
MARU AHUES: And
you can, of course,
use that for authentication
and security.
PENG YING: And if you want to
just test the discoverable,
you can set the
discoverable status
to draft, which will enforce the
white list of only the accounts
that you've shared your
merchant account with.
So in this case, we've
shared this merchant account
with our test account,
gwallet.demo@gmail.com.
MARU AHUES: So
once we have that,
let's look at how we
can then take your Quick
Start that you've already
had running locally
to test your own discoverable.
So we're going to
assume that, of course,
you've created
your discoverable.
And if you haven't, you can
go to the documentation,
find information
on how to do that.
And take your Quick
Start, and an easy way
would be to go to
appspot.com and create your
on App Engine site from here.
So just create a
new application.
Click on Create Application.
And that's going to give
you an application ID.
Once you do that, again,
going to the web.xml.
PENG YING: Oh, it's app XML.
MARU AHUES: Oh, not the web.xml.
I'm sorry.
Go into the appengine-web.xml
Thank you, Peng.
And let me see where it is.
PENG YING: It's at the
very top-- application.
MARU AHUES: Here.
So in here, let's say
that I'm using wobs-maru.
Then I'll just put the
application name in there.
Once I have that, then I can go
into my Google Eclipse Plugin
here and click on
Deploy to App Engine.
When I do that, you can
just click on Deploy.
And that's going to take all
our code that we have locally
and deploy to App Engine.
So now you'll be able to
access the same site that we
were running locally
on App Engine.
PENG YING: Takes a few seconds.
MARU AHUES: But it's very easy.
It can't get any
easier than this.
So once it's running
here, we should
be able to go to
wobs-maru, and then I
have here my Quick
Start running.
It's going to take
a couple seconds,
because it's still loading.
Great.
So now we have it running.
So now, I use the URL
on my Merchant Callback
Configuration, as I
showed you before.
And this is how Peng was
testing using the application.
So when he's doing a
request from the phone,
that's hitting my web service
here at wobs-maru.appspot.com.
And we're returning back
the object for that user.
So let's see how this works.
Let's look for web
service in the web.xml.
And web service is mapped to
the WOB web service handler
servlet.
If we look at that,
at the servlet,
we'll see that we are also
creating a WOB credentials
object with the credentials
that we set for this project.
We get the JSON
request from Google,
and then we generate a response.
The response will either be
an approved or a rejected
response.
In our testing, we
have it approved,
but you can also uncomment
and send a rejected response.
In here, we also, for
an approved response,
we have to send back
the loyalty object,
and we do that using the same
loyalty vertical class that we
showed before when we were
creating the Save To Wallet
object.
Once we do that, we generate
the JWT with the response,
and we send it back to Google.
Google gets the response,
and then shows the object
on the Google Wallet App.
So that's it.
PENG YING: Yeah, that's it.
It's really easy.
We hope that this has been
informative, and gets you up
and started with the
Google Wallet Objects API
as quickly as possible.
This is just one more
video in a series
of GDLs about the
Wallet Objects API.
If you have
additional questions,
or if you want to find out more,
stay tuned to Google Developers
Live, or take a look
at our documentation.
We'll have deeper dives into
all of the different aspects
of Google Wallet Objects
within our series.
And that concludes this
Google Developers Live.
Thanks for tuning in, and
we'll see you next time.
MARU AHUES: See you soon.
Thank you.